[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look then at what is on
the front pages as they arrive time to
see what is making the headlines with
the daily walls consultant editor andrew
pearce and the daily mirrors associate
editor kev maguire good to see both of
you
so to the front pages then let's start
with the telegraph
it has the headline scale back christmas
plans echoing government guidance
following the highest ever number of
covert cases in a day 78 610
similarly the eye proclaims don't mix
with friends unless you have to
the express wishes its readers a very
sensible christmas
the guardian leads on a warning to cut
back on socializing as covet cases
surged to a record high
the times with a similar front page with
professor chris witte urging people to
scale back on plans over christmas or in
the run-up to it
that record high figure for daily cases
is also the big story for the financial
times
meanwhile the metro declares mortuary
vulture to die in jail covering the case
of murder david fuller who sexually
abused bodies in a morgue
and the son leading with katie price
avoiding a prison sentence following her
car crash early this year after
admitting to being under the influence
of alcohol and drugs
well let's um
get the thoughts of andrew pierce and
kevin mcguire christmas cheer and all
that kevin this is this is hardcore now
isn't it
yeah absolutely this was more scrooge
than uh santa from chris whitney
england's chief medical officer who i
think is being pretty good all the way
through this covered pandemic but he's
looking at those figures uh says there
are now two epidemics there's delta and
the omicron 78 000 fresh cases new
record 10 000 more than the peak uh last
time
nailed on after christmas hospitals are
going to be full cases are going to go
up so he's saying right this christmas
let's uh let's not mix the way you would
normally don't mix with friends unless
you have to prioritize it was a very
different message from him than we had
from boris johnson the prime minister
who was
was more positive and wasn't uh full of
so much doom and gloom and it's either
johnson doesn't feel it or he's
terrified to say it after his mp 100 or
so
rebelled against uh restrictions in
england which to be honest i'm pretty
modest
when you listen to witty you listen to
the experts you think whoa those uh
those restrictions may not be enough but
pressure will now grow if there's gonna
be a lock down by stealth and people are
not going out they're not going into the
shops not going into pubs restaurants in
the same way the pressure is going to
grow on the chancellor sunaku is in
california at the moment
the pressure is going to grow on him to
actually bring back a scheme to help
these businesses which could be
clobbered yet again yes
in california on a business trip i guess
but as you say
lots of lots of questions about the
money but just in terms of us the public
first of all andrew in the absence of
tougher restrictions from government we
have to do this ourselves don't don't we
kind of have to circuit break ourselves
if we want to see our older relatives at
christmas
yeah look and i i think it's right we
should we should think of think think of
this for ourselves do it ourselves we've
been
uh we've been almost infantilized in
times during this pandemic um people uh
it's the same in scotland it's guidance
they're not telling people they can't
mix that's advising people three
households only over over the christmas
period it's all advice people are being
given advice and they either follow it
or they don't
andrew we've had that advice from the
chief medical officer we have not had it
from the government
well this youth medical officer
speaks for the government i mean i think
that's fine but
that's the point that people watch that
press conference today the news
conference at downing street that there
was there was different messaging now
from the the politician who stood there
and the and the man who's going to wait
and watch and see the hospitalizations
uh grow
yeah well look i i don't i don't want
the prime minister to tell me what i can
and can't do uh and the many chief
medical officers giving his medical
opinion and you'll find another uh
scientist or have a complete opinion uh
so um uh people will have to work it out
for themselves and i think we're big
enough and ugly enough to do that anna
um and the fact is the prime minister's
also has will be feeling much more
restrained about uh telling people what
they can and can't do after the the
beating the government had in the
commons yesterday
half of tory back benches voted against
the government there will be many
ministers who wanted to do the same and
i think if they were even to contemplate
plan c
plan c which is even more social
distancing shutting pubs shutting
restaurants i think there'd be cabinet
resignations and it would be the end
even if cases sorry to persist with you
but even if cases are are as high as
might be predicted in the coming days
and
because so far death toll i think
yesterday was 165 it's been much higher
uh the death toll still isn't uh it's
not keeping pace with anything like the
rate of uh transmissibility we know it's
much more transmissible but we still
don't have any evidence yet that the
that uh omicron is more lethal
than the delta variant in fact we
suspect so far according to the evidence
it isn't and still the evidence seems to
be it's like a very serious gold or the
flu that that milder issue was was
questioned today by chris whittie there
wasn't it kevin i mean he said you know
he cautioned against anybody's presuming
this is milder at this point
no no he didn't he said there could be
over interpretation of uh some of the
data coming out of south africa but the
point the point is
the new the new mutation might kill
fewer people per
thousand hundred thousand infections
than delta but if you've got far more
infections it's going to go up the
absolute number of people in hospital
and dying will then go up and as a
public health expert he wants to nip
that in the bud and prevent it happening
because we have had times in the past
when more than a thousand people a day
have been dying at the moment it's just
under a thousand a week which is still a
remarkable figure that's uh that can
just be considered uh
relatively low and almost
shrugged off but it can get out of hand
very very quickly uh i'm not quite sure
what the answer what the answer is i
don't want to go back into another
lockdown
but if all if all the health experts are
public health experts are saying that is
the only way
to prevent
mass casualties yet again then the
government would have to consider it and
would need to come up with a scheme to
compensate workers and businesses
there's no sign of that but boris
johnson is
it's the key to stomach charge that he's
too weak now and it might begin to stick
because he is he's frightened of too
many in his own party who bully him and
he may not be able to take decisions
that are in the national interest as a
result and that is a problem with prime
minister you need prime ministers to be
strong and you need to be bold and he
and he is weak and he's frightened
well but the biggest change so far is
the advice to work from home and that is
that is that is kicking in i mean in
london central london it's much quieter
uh lots much more restaurants are
closing bars are closing uh we know that
bookings for cinemas and theaters are
down so people are working for them
that's a major change uh and i mean
whitehall has not been back to work
frankly since the first lockdown so
there is that that i think the
government has moved dramatically in
advising people if you can work from
home stay at home that's a big change
and that's going to reduce transmission
the potential for transmissibility an
awful lot i think yeah but the
transition
might not go any further than that at
this stage
the truth is only a minority of people
can work from home because many people
have jobs you have to go to whether
you're in the health service whether
you're in retail whether you're driving
a cab or a bus or a lorry i think the
the office for national statistics last
time round i think it was only one in
four people at the people working from
home which meant three three and four
were going to work he went to places
like middlesbrough or burnley i think
there were two that were picked out
almost everybody was still going to work
because they had to and they they will
be at risk now if you don't want them to
go to work you will have to follow them
again that scheme will need to be
brought back and i i just wonder if
the prime minister and the chancellor
are just capable of getting their heads
around that and making some decisions
that would be tough there's no question
about it but they would be in the
national interest if they're going to
stop hundreds if not thousands of people
dying
yeah i suppose the difficulty is there's
a lag in cases
because by the time you've got a symptom
you get a pcr takes another day there's
a lag in hospitalization so we go back
to the baked in
uh situation in primary health care
after christmas is what chris whittie
said today
so all of this is baked in and cases are
doubling as we now know in less than two
days so you look at the ft the figure of
78 000 uh that is the cases that doesn't
report all actually of the infections um
so very swiftly andrew to go back to
plan c you know this this goes way
beyond anything we've had before which
takes us to what jenny harry said today
that we are in in a sense the most
dangerous part of the pandemic so far
despite the vaccination effort
yeah but we've also but we're now
they're they're dramatically increasing
the
the the booster jabs 670 000 today that
will increase again i suspected that was
yesterday's figure i suspect today's vid
will be higher i know we've got to get
it up to a million but that's going to
make a big difference
and we know that the efficacy if you've
had your your third jab is up to 70
percent and so far i i say it again the
evidence is that this uh this variant
doesn't make you as ill as a delta
variant so i think we've got to rely on
the booster job we've got to rely on it
being rolled out dramatically there are
queues all over the country for it i
know kevin thinks it was all
it was diversionary politics get away
from partygate i'm sure there's an
element of that but actually i think
it's a great triumph what's going on
with the uh booster jam it's a great
track yet again to the nhs the army and
the fact it's being delivered pretty
successfully
oh no on sunday sunday evening at um
eight o'clock which is when the press
conference we had today should have been
held because johnson didn't want any
questions back then i think the the
message is probably right it's just the
the messenger uh has played so many
tricks and you could see
he was talking about a tidal wave on the
uh on on sunday and then he comes along
today he's basically shrugging his
shoulders a bit and he's not he's not
really offering anything else while
chris whitney next to him as some coats
picked out
it was like two different press
conferences one given by whittier mum
given by boris johnson
yeah well we will talk more no doubt
there's so much to discuss on this uh
you know and uh certainly chris wood he
did caution against this idea of
mildness because if you want to rely on
people's behavior now to control the
surge then that's one big area that
might dictate people's behavior i
suppose that's uh one element anyway
lots more to come including is boris
johnson losing support among influential
tory back benches and is his political
future in danger all of that to come
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now andrew pierce and
kevin mcguire uh off the back of omicron
obviously the measures that were brought
in that bruising encounter uh in
parliament and that vote uh over a
hundred uh touring ps the telegraph
looking into the into the the
implications of that now andrew
suggestion that people can email in
letters of no confidence during the
holidays goodness me
now that's that's that's that will be
really not welcomed in downing street at
all because the house of commons now
gets in goes into recess tomorrow
uh and we get the by-election result did
we get the by-election result which
could have a bearing on letters of
letters of confidence but what graham
brady the chairman of the 1922 committee
has said is if if mps want to email
their letters in during the recess
that's fine as long as there's a
follow-up phone call and he can verify
it's genuine now in the past it's always
been
the letter actually had to be handed
over
so that's quite a dramatic change and
that will be a cause for concern in
number ten because um people are over
the christmas period um who knows what
political difficulties may accelerate
for the prime minister those letters
could start coming i suspect there are
already some letters um i don't know
that but i suspect there's a few
probably from the usual suspects um but
um we the telegraph has also crunched
those numbers of the hundred mps who
didn't vote for the prime minister
yesterday and it includes the six
officers of the 1922 committee the
treasurer the secretary the chairman all
six uh these are really influential
people in the back benches and none of
them supported the prime minister
yesterday now they would say that's not
on a what if you like on an ideological
or a party political issue it was all to
do with plan b
but it's pretty worrying if you're a
boris johnson supporter yeah do you mind
if i move on uh kevin to do the real
world issues also facing the government
which is inflation families feeling the
pinch inflation at a 10-year high that's
also a big a big deal too
this is why i don't think it's going to
get any better for the prime minister
indeed will get worse because inflation
at 5.1 on cpr 7.1 on rpi which is used
to calculate for instance rail fare
increases student loan fees this is
really going to squeeze people's incomes
because wages are not growing up at this
rate so real wages are falling and then
in
april we're going to have national
insurance going up 1.25
so
it's going to make it worse in terms of
people's uh family family budgets and i
think people will kick back and rebel
and all the issues all the problems with
the prime minister will just get worse
because people will feel they're being
treated badly
kevin
and andrew so much to talk about at the
moment would you believe um just over a
week to christmas thank you both very
much indeed thank you